on quitte l'eau des fontaines pour
rejoindre celle de la Loire rallier
l'océan Atlantique en suivant le cours
du fleuve en kayak un défi de plus de
1000 km que s'est lancé Alexis pechard à
25 ans se vogia est devenu une star des
réseaux sociaux sur lesquels il partage
son périple partie de la source au Mont
Gerbier de Jonc il y a deux mois il est
en ce moment en Indre-et-Loire où il
s'arrête pour aller à la rencontre des
habitants Benjamin Vatel l'a rencontré à
Amboise
[Musique]
a commencé son aventure sur la loi le
jeune homme raconte son parcours avec
bonne humeur dans des vidéos de quelques
minutes qu'il monte lui-même pendant
plusieurs heures durant ses pauses
je vais prendre le matin en fait c'est
ça
petit réveil pour le Coran avec lever de
soleil les vaches etc l'idée c'est de
réussir à remonter dedans au milieu de
l'eau s'appelle un dessalage je crois
allez on va tester ça ça va être drôle
pas tomber dès le début il est seul sur
son kayak mais rencontre chaque jour de
nouvelles personnes c'est à dire que
vidéo TikTok ou pas Alexis pechard fait
la descente de la Loire après ces vidéos
me permettent des rencontres
des découvertes etc et ça enrichit mon
aventure et ça c'est vraiment top les
rencontres lui permettent de résoudre
ses problèmes cette embarcation par
exemple n'est pas la même qu'elles sont
au départ elle lui a été prêtée par un
club de canoë qui l'a rencontré près de
Nevers tente
il l'emporte avec lui plus de 30 kg de
matériel du coup dans ce saut là j'ai
tout mon matériel vidéo le les batteries
le drone mon petit bouquin qui me sert à
en apprendre plus tous les jours sur la
Loire et voilà le kayakiste en profite
pour visiter les villes qu'il traverse
en à peine deux mois il a construit une
communauté de 140000 fans qui suivent
ces péripéties quotidiennes lors de son
passage à Amboise ce matin certains de
ses abonnés ont fait le déplacement pour
le rencontrer
j'ai découvert grâce à Tik Tok et
Instagram
j'ai découvert sur la Loire et je me
suis dit que c'était proche de chez moi
ces rencontres ralentissent malgré tout
Alexis qui espère tout de même arriver à
la fin du voyage à Saint-Nazaire aux
alentours du 20 août avant de commencer
une nouvelle aventure